I recently shaved my head and people
have been making fun of me in the
comments. Some of them quite funny
actually. But this should make me feel
sad, lost. But when I get home and I see
her lying there, I'm automatically
lifted with joy for what she can do is
completely
[Music]
fabulous. Welcome to Tech City. This is
Brian coming to you guys today with a
review of the GTX 1070 Gaming X from
MSI. This time around they've included
RGB LEDs on the side and even integrated
one into the back plate. Definitely
stepping up the game for cosmetics.
Though it doesn't just stop with
cosmetics. This cooler is a heavy
implementation with the card weighing in
at roughly 1.1 kg. The VRM is a 10-phase
design with UBIC QM
3816N6 MOSFETs with the high side which
is rated at 51 amps and the low side
rated at 117 amps integrated into one
circuit forming what is known as the
dual end MOSFET design. The super far
chokes are rated at 60 amps and MSI have
included solidstate 8K caps on the
board. Okay, okay, okay, I get it. Let's
hit those benchmarks.
[Music]
Oh, heat, heat.
As you can see from the benchmarks, this
card was very impressive out of the box,
sporting an overclock that hits over 2
GHz at all times without me even
touching anything. I also managed to get
a little bit extra out of it in terms of
overclocks, especially on the memory,
which is also from Samsung, by the way.
Though, the best thing about this card
was it was just whisper quiet the whole
way through benchmarking from stock
settings to custom overclocks. Let's
take a quick
listen. So, looking over this graphics
card, there really is nothing to fault
here, except for one thing. I'd like to
see a dual BIOS if possible. Though, it
does have a really solid build quality.
It has the cosmetics. It has the low
acoustics, and it also features a PCB
size that is extra wide, with MSI
implementing their own custom VRM.
Moving over the front of the unit, the
red accents light up red, too, which
would fit perfectly into a red and black
themed build. Looking at the outputs,
you have three display ports, one HDMI
2.0, and also a DVI out. It has SLI
support for up to three-way and features
two PCIe connections, one a six pin and
one an 8 pin. Also, power consumption
was really good as well, coming under
that of the 980 Ti when overclocked and
both out of the box settings. As for the
performance, the GTX 1070 was beating
the 980 Ti out of the box. Though, once
the 980 Ti overclocked, it did edge it
out in a lot of those games. Ultimately,
however, this card is a card that hits
all the boxes in my opinion, and the
included software is actually usable,
allowing you to control the LED colors
and mix it with other products like
their motherboard. You can also select
the overclock mode and have graphs being
displayed in real time to monitor temps
and whatnot while gaming. As for
pricing, you can currently pick this
card up for around about 699 AUD or
around 408 USD if you're in the US from
Amazon. Though honestly, if you are in
Australia, you're probably better off
just going to Amazon in the States and
then just converting to AUD. I think
that way you'll save around
$150, which is pretty huge, though.
Again, great job from MSI and is a
really solid card that I can recommend
to pretty much anyone out there. Anyway,
that's about it for me today. If you
like this video, then be sure to hit
that like button and if you have any
questions or comments about the GTX 1070
Gaming X, then be sure to drop a comment
in the comment section below and I'll
get back to you as soon as I can. Also,
let me know, do you have a GTX 1070 at
the moment? If so, what model? If not,
let me know. Would you want one? If so,
why? And if not, why not? Would love to
hear your comments as usual. And I'll
catch you guys in another tech video
very soon. Peace out for now. Bye.